If you saw a worm hole in reality
it would appear round spherical,
a bit like a black hole light from the
other side passes through and gives you a
window to a far away place once crossed,
the other side comes for the
interview with your old home.
Now receding into that
shimmering spherical window,
but our wormholes real or are they just
magic disguised as physics and maths?
If they are real, how do they
work and where can we find them?
For most of human history,
we thought space was pretty simple.
A big flat stage where the
events are the universe unfold.
Even if you take down the
set of planets and stars,
there's still something left that's empty.
Stage is space and it exists
unchanging and eternal.
Einstein's theory of
relativity change that.
It says that space and time makeup that
stage together and they aren't the same
everywhere. The things on the
stage can affect the stage itself.
Stretching and warping it.
If the old stage was like
unmoving hardwood Einstein
stage is more like a water
bed.
This kind of elastic space can be bent
and maybe even torn and patched together,
which could make wormholes possible.
Let's see what that
would look like in two d.
Our universe is like a big flat
sheet bent in just the right way.
Wormholes could connect to very,
very distant spots with a short
bridge that you could cross almost
instantaneously enabling you to travel
the universe even faster than the speed
of light.
So where can we find a wormhole
presently only on paper?
General relativity says
they might be possible,
but that doesn't mean they have to exist.
General relativity is
a mathematical theory.
It's a set of equations that
have many possible answers,
but not all maths describes reality,
but they are theoretically possible.
And there are different kinds.
The first kind of wormholes to be
theorized where Einstein, Rosen bridges,
they describe every black hole as a
sort of portal to an infinite parallel
universe. Let's try to
picture them in two D. Again,
empty space time is flat
but curved by objects on it.
If we compress that objects,
spacetime gets more curved around it.
Eventually spacetime becomes so walked.
But it has no choice but to
collapse into a black hole.
A one way barrier forms the event horizon,
which anything can enter,
but nothing can escape trapped forever
at the singularity, at its core,
but maybe there is no singularity here.
One possibility is that the other side
of the event horizon looks a bit like our
universe. Again, that
mirrored upside down.
Wet time runs backwards in our universe.
Things fall into the black hole in the
parallel universe with backwards time.
The mirror black hole is spewing
things out a bit like a big bag.
This is called a white hole.
Unfortunately, Einstein,
Rosen bridges can't actually be crossed.
It takes an infinite amount of time to
cross over to the opposite university and
they crimped shots in the middle.
If you go into a black hole,
you won't become the stuff coming out of
the Whitehall. You'll only become debt,
so to travel the cosmos
in the blink of an eye,
humans need a different kind of wormhole,
a traversable wormhole.
If string theory or one of its variations
is the correct description of our
universe,
then we could be lucky and our universe
might even have a tangled web of
countless wormholes already.
Shortly after the Big Bang
quantum fluctuations in the
universe at the smallest
scales far, far smaller than
an atom may have created. Many,
many traversable wormholes
threaded through them.
Our strings called cosmic strings in
the first billionth of a trillionth of a
second. After the Big Bang, the
ends of these tiny, tiny worm holes,
we'll pull the my chair's apart,
scattering them through the universe.
F wormholes were made
in the early universe,
whether with cosmic
strings or some other way,
they could be all over just
waiting to be discovered.
One might even be closer than
we realize from the outside.
Black holes and wormholes
can look very similar.
Leading some physicists to suggest the
supermassive black holes in the center of
galaxies are actually wormholes.
It will be very hard to go all the way
to the center of the Milky Way to find
out though,
but that's okay.
There might be an equally extremely hard
way to get our hands on a worm hole.
We could try to make one
to be traversable and useful.
There are a few properties we
want a wormhole to have. First,
it must obviously connects to distant
parts of space time like your bedroom and
the bathroom or earth and Jupiter.
Second, it should not contain any event
horizons which would blog two way travel.
Third,
it should be sufficiently sized so that
the gravitational force is don't kill
human travelers.
The biggest problem we have to solve
is keeping our worm holes open.
No matter how we make wormholes,
gravity tries to close them.
Gravity wants to pinch it close
and cut the bridge. Leaving.
Oh need black holes at the ends.
Whether it's a traversable worm hole with
both hands and hours or a wormhole to
another universe,
it will try to close unless we have
something propping it open for very old
string theory worm holes.
That's the cosmic strings
job for manmade wormholes.
We need a new ingredient exotic matter.
This isn't anything like we find
on earth or even anti matter.
It's something totally new and different
and exciting with crazy properties like
nothing that's ever been seen before.
Exotic matter is stuff
that has a negative mass,
positive mass like people and planets
and everything else in the universe is
attractive because of gravity,
but negative mass would be repulsive.
It would push you away. This makes a
kind of anti gravity that props open.
Our wormholes and exotic matter must
exert enormous pressure to push spacetime
open greater even than the pressure at
the centers of neutron stars with exotic
matter. We could weave space
time, however we see fit.
We may even have a candidate for this
exotic matter. The vacuum of space itself,
quantum fluctuations in empty space
constantly creating pairs of particles and
antiparticles only for them to be
at [inaudible] and instant later.
The vacuum of space is boiling with them
and we can already manipulate them to
produce an effect. Similar to the
negative mass were looking for.
We could use this to
stabilize our worm holes.
Once we're keeping it open,
the ends would start together so we'd
have to move them around to interesting
places.
We could start by wiring the Saudi system,
leaving one end of each worm
hole in orbit around the earth.
We could flag others into deep space.
The earth could be a wormhole hub for
a vast interstellar human civilization
spread over light shares, but
only a wormhole away. However,
wormholes have a dark site.
Even opening a single worm hole kind of
breaks the universe in fundamental ways,
potentially creating time travel paradox
is and violating the causal structure
of the universe.
Many scientists think that there's not
only means they should be impossible to
make, but that it's impossible for
them to exist at all. So for now,
we only know that wormholes exist in
our hearts and on paper in the form of
equations. We know you want to
know more about universe stuff.
So we're trying something
new codes Casandra and
brilliant to are collaborating
on a six part video series about our
favorite science and space things.
Thanks to their help.
There will be more videos on this
channel in the next six months.
[inaudible] has worked with brilliant
for a while now and we love what they're
doing in a nutshell.
Brilliant.
Helps you to get ahead by mastering
maths and science skills through actively
solving,
challenging and fascinating problems
to support our collaboration with them.
Visit brilliant.org/nutshell
and sign up for free today.
The first 688 people that use the link
or get 20% off that annual premium
subscription.